we like to communicate with our friends
and families by several multi media we
use whatsapp Facebook Twitter Email etc
now sales also don't like to stay in
isolation they also want to talk to each
other and the way they talk to each
other is via cell signaling which is
based on receptor and ligand interaction
now just the way we use different kind
of multimedia cells can also use
different signals or different ligands
which have different chemical nature for
example cell can use protein type
signaling molecules like insulin it can
also use cholesterol derivatives like
all the steroid hormones also amino acid
derivatives like thyroid hormones and
one unusual of that is a gaseous
molecule nitric oxide now that's weird
right so all these are amino acid
derivative or something soluble now how
are gaseous molecule could induce a
signaling system and how cell can
communicate with a gaseous molecule the
whole video is about the mechanism by
which nitric oxide could work like a
signaling molecule and conveys certain
messages inside the cell and this
finding is was pretty weird but very
important and new in the field of cell
biology and as a result 1998 Nobel Prize
in medicine was awarded to Robert forgot
Louie ignarro
and Fred Murad so we'll look at a little
bit of their work and try to understand
how nitric oxide can evoke signaling
pathway and by which interactors it work
on the cells now freed murad did a nice
experiment where in the prepared culture
muscle cells he injected nitroglycerin
and the observation that he found is
when he injected nitroglycerin the
smooth muscle cell relaxes
and also in the cultures when he put
several drugs nitroglycerin etc he saw
smooth muscle relaxant muscle relaxation
not only that when he bubbled nitric
oxide in this culture he saw the same
kind of phenomena that tells him that
nitroglycerin or similar drugs which
sort of cause muscle relaxation work via
intermediate which is nitric oxide now
they became one step forward now let's
try to understand how this exactly
happens at a molecular level so here is
a bundle of smooth muscle cells and this
mud muscle cells are innervated by
several blood vessels right now this is
look at a portion of blood vessel and
the smooth muscle cell so this is the
higher magnification of that now people
had a confusing observation in the field
whenever they injected acetylcholine in
the muscle cells directly by
intramuscular injections they saw the
muscles contract but whenever they
injected acetylcholine in nearby blood
vessels associated with the muscle they
saw instead of conscious constriction
the muscles relaxed there's a total
opposite observation and people wanted
to find the mechanisms of it as a result
now we know that when we inject the
acetylcholine in the nearby blood
vessels it activates g-protein coupled
receptors which ultimately activates
phospholipase c phospholipase c
ultimately activates ip3
which allows store operated calcium
release and calcium level increases in
the cytosol once calcium level is
increased it is sensed by calcium and
calmodulin complex which activates
nitric oxide synthase now nitric oxide
synthetase
synthesized nitric oxide from l-arginine
it converts it to l-citrulline and
nitric oxide
now since nitric oxide is a diffusible
molecule it diffuses out from the blood
vessel cells and gets into the nearby
muscle cells now point to be noted that
nitric oxide is a transient signal
because it's half-life is for few
seconds now suddenly the muscle cell
sees a huge amount of nitric oxide and
the sensor by which nitric oxide could
be sensed in the muscle cell is nitric
oxide receptors which is lot similar to
the hemoglobin or myoglobin having a
heme group inside it however whenever
the nitric oxide bind to its receptor
which has a heme group it converts gtp
into cyclic GMP now just like cyclic a
MP cyclic GMP is another second
messenger molecule cyclic GMP binds to
protein kinase G now protein kinase g is
a serine threonine kinase and which is
kind of present in all the eukaryotes
from Paramecium to human and protein
kinase G is pretty conserved protein
kinase G is important for metabolism of
sperm nucleic acid synthesis with muscle
relaxation cell division and many other
functions today we look at that how
smooth muscle relaxation is induced by
protein kinase G now we understood that
protein kinase G is activated by cyclic
GMP binding which is indeed facilitated
by nitric oxide dependent signaling
right now how does protein kinase G
evoke at a cellular level the smooth
muscle relaxation what protein kinase G
does is phosphorylate several targets
which allows this cross bridge formation
in order to in order for the muscle to
constrict the cross which need to form
now protein kinase G with the complex
molecular pathway prevent this cross
bridge formation by phosphorylating
several downstream target and as a
result the smooth muscle cells cannot
contract and they relax so this is how
nitric oxide work via protein
is she to allow smooth muscle
construction constriction and this kind
of mechanism was pretty new at the end
of 19th century and that is why it will
lead to a noble discovery and I hope you
enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you